What's going on everybody? Welcome to
another video. I happened to call into a
Hebrew Israelite stream, uh, the IUIC
Oklahoma stream, and they were talking
about the Trinity. And man, these dudes
did not know what they were talking
about. So, I called in just to have a
little fun. Let's see how that went.
[music]
Sky [music]
is God.
>> Oh, we got to call him. We got to call
him. Hey, caller. Caller, you're live on
the air. This cast down imaginations.
What's your name? Where you from?
>> What's up, fellas? Uh, my name is Avery.
Um, I'm a Christian.
>> Hey, what's going on?
>> What's going on?
>> What's your thoughts on the topic?
>> Nothing much. Uh, I hear you guys
talking about the Trinity.
What's your thoughts on the What's your
thoughts on the trinity?
>> A trinitarian.
>> You say you are a trinitarian.
>> What is that?
>> Yeah. Turn your phone down so you can
hear us talk, man. You You listening to
the echo responding late.
>> Or whatever you got in the background.
>> Can you guys hear me? Okay.
>> Yeah, we can hear you.
>> Yeah. Something you got in the
background. You You delayed listening to
whatever that is.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Okay. You good? Okay, there you go.
Okay, so you explained the trinity to
us. What's your thoughts on it?
>> Yeah. So, uh my thoughts on the trinity
is that um one, it is definitely
biblical. I think that there's some
fundamental things that as I was
listening to you guys, there's some uh
things that you guys are conflating when
it comes to the Trinity. Um I just
wanted to like just quickly lay out what
it is and then we could probably go from
there. You know, I'm following y'all's
leads, so
>> Yeah. Yeah. Give us what you think it
is.
biblically.
>> Yeah. So, so the trini, so the trinity,
the trinity is the concept that God,
there's one divine essence, one divine
being that exists as three distinct
persons. And what from what I was
hearing, it sounds like you guys were
conflating being and personhood. Being
is what a thing is, what you are.
>> Um, your makeup, the properties that
make you what you are, and your
personhood is who you are. So when we're
saying that there's one God that exists
as three distinct persons, we're saying
there's one being, right? One what with
three who.
>> That's what
Hey, are you this guy on the video? Cuz
this is what exactly what he just said
on the video that we watching. Are you
this guy in the video that we just
watched?
>> No, I'm not I'm not out.
>> Okay. So you repeating the same talking
points. Okay. All right. Um was that it?
Was that it?
>> Yeah. Say that we picked up. So you said
three what? Three one what and three
who's.
>> That's right. One being three persons.
>> Okay. So that's it.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah. I think that we should
go ahead and get into that because you
guys are saying
>> I do got a question.
>> Three gods or three beings?
>> I understand that. I got a question
though. So
>> with that understanding, can you explain
John 14 and 28?
>> Oh yeah. That's that's simple, man. Uh
where Jesus says that you should
rejoice. You should be happy for me that
I'm that I said I'm going away going to
my father because the father is greater
than I.
>> So hold on. So my question is if they
are if it's one God that they they
coexist equally that that's that's
trinitarian, right? They they coexist
equally as one God. The father, the son,
the holy ghost. They're all equal. The
three distinct persons that coexist
equally. How is the father greater than
the son?
Yeah. So this is uh just talking about a
a local standard where the father is in
heaven, right? And Jesus came down,
humbled himself, took on the form of a
servant.
>> But he's not speak but can we read the
scripture cuz I may maybe maybe we're
confused. Maybe you're confused on a sec
because Christ is not speaking from a
local standpoint. He says I'm going to
the father. That's heaven.
>> Exactly.
>> He says I'm going. So that's not local.
That's in heaven.
>> And he says the father is greater than
I.
Yeah, that's that's why he says you
should be you should rejoice that I say
I'm going back. I'm going to the father.
You you wouldn't be sad if you if you if
you knew what this meant for me. I'm
going to the father for the father is
greater than I. You should be happy
about that that I'm going to the father
because that is in a lesser state.
>> So, so, so it would make more sense if
he said I'm going back to my original
form.
>> So, here's the here's my question. If
Christ
said what he said,
>> so let me ask you this. It still floats
>> cuz you said he's at a lesser form. So
how are they co-equal?
>> No.
>> If Christ at a lesser form
>> I said he's at a lesser lesser state in
in that he has humbled himself and has
come down. He has condescended
>> to humanity. So where father is where
the father did not condescend ascended.
>> It's descended. It's not condescend.
>> Who has condescended?
>> It's not condescend. It's descended.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's condescending. When you
come when you go to
>> condescend is not the word. Condescend
is not the word. It's descending. Stop
saying condescend. That's not the word.
>> It's DC.
>> You're not You're not understanding what
you're not understanding what I'm
saying. When condescend means to go
lower than where you are or to go lower,
right?
>> No, it doesn't. No. No sir. Hold on.
Condescend.
>> Condescend. And I just want to put it on
the screen for the for the viewers. Um,
condescend.
>> I tell you, they don't even know what
they talking about.
>> Condescend means to show feelings of
superiority by be patronizing. That's
not what it means. Descend means to come
down. Descend. And descend means to go.
>> Descended means to come down. Past
tense.
>> Okay, I got you guys. Can I read? Cuz
I'm a Marryiam Webster's dictionary. I
agree with you that that's one of the
definitions you read. That's one of
them. Here's the second definition.
>> Hey, hey, watch it. I would tell you
this. This is what Paul was talking
about of striving about right.
>> This is exactly what he was talking
about.
>> Go ahead.
>> I don't mean to cut you off. Okay. I
appreciate it. Uh the other definition
here on Mariam McMaster's dictionary
says to descend to a less formal or
dignified level. So that's what I'm
that's what I mean by when I say Christ
condescended. He descended to a less
formal or dignified level. the same God
>> had that form of God and he took on the
form of a servant. So that's him
condescending to our level.
>> So let me ask the correct word.
>> Okay. All right. So So you're saying on
a on a low level, uh he was locally.
That's what he was saying. Okay. Well,
what about Daniel? What about Daniel the
7th chapter?
>> Let's go there. Can you explain this?
>> I'd like Where we going? We're going
Daniel the 7th chapter and the 13th
verse.
>> Okay. All right. cuz cuz uh you said
okay that was him on a local level and
he's saying I'm going back to my
heavenly state cuz my father is greater
than I. So when I'm there I guess they
merge back together. I'm not sure. Uh I
don't see
>> not that they merge back together but
that he regains that he's exalted again.
>> Wait a minute. So wait a wait a minute.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute. People is
it two people in heaven when he goes
back or is this just one person?
>> It's you have the father, the son, and
the holy spirit. It's three persons,
brother. So he so so he so he is always
his own son even when he's his own
father in heaven.
>> No see that no see this is the
conflation that I was talking about
earlier when you when we're saying that
there's three distinct persons. We're
making it clear and I hope that you like
we can move forward with this. It's
clear from my position that the father,
the son, and the spirit are distinct
persons. They're not each other. The
father is not the son. The son is not
the spirit and vice versa. They're
distinct persons yet they are unified in
their essence. Okay. So
all right are two different things.
>> I'm you can end this real quick with
this crazy this stupid Christianity. We
are all of the same essence when you put
off the flesh. What what are y'all
Christians talking? This is stupid man.
When you flesh and blood wait flesh and
blood cannot enter into the kingdom of
heaven. All of us are going to be spirit
in heaven. [laughter]
We are all going to be the same essence.
So now he's just preaching and yelling,
"Huh? Oh, this is just stupid." There's
no argument that we're hearing. No
argument. This is just stupid. Uh, wow.
How could you just be saying this is
Christianity? Nuh-uh. Nuh-uh. Nuh-uh.
Look at this. All this crying, all this
yelling over, but no argument against
what I said. Now, if he's trying to say,
"Well, human beings also share the same
essence." Awesome. Whoopde-doo. Um,
unfortunately for you, Mr. purple gold
ranger. Uh the human essence is
divisible. We are even though we are
like in essence, we are different human
beings. We do not have the same will. We
do not have the same action. We don't
even have uh we're divided in space and
time. So you are a different human being
than I am. Even though we share the same
human essence, when it comes to God and
the divine being, the father, son, and
holy spirit are indivisible in their
essence. They are uh inseparable in
their essence. They're not, you know,
uh, uh, bound by time or space. Um, they
they are eternal and infinite. Um,
united in will and action. There's
nothing that they do that is separable
from each other. So, bring an actual
argument instead of doing all this
crying and complaining, talking about
Christianity is stupid.
>> Y'all are itch. This is stupid, man.
>> Okay.
>> Hey, this is Let's break this down cuz I
I appreciate that.
>> Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Can I Can
I Can I respond to that?
>> No.
>> Hold on. Wait. Listen. Cuz you keep this
You went off of Christianity, but you're
not giving me stupid
every Hey. Hey, guess. Watch this. Watch
this. Hey. So, watch this. So, the
angels are a are God, too? Because
>> No,
>> wait a minute. What? Wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait. My question is, what
essence are they made of?
>> Yeah. So, so the the angels have a
created finite.
>> What essence?
>> What essence are they made of? [music]
>> Guys, can you guys allow me to you guys?
>> No, I'm just asking you.
>> Did y'all hear that? One of them said,
"I'm just making up words now. And I'm
just making up stuff. These dudes don't
know what finite means. They don't know
what it means to be finite and create."
This is insane. So now they're trying to
make the argument like, okay then, so
what what makes the ang the essence of
the angels different from God's essence?
>> This is IUIC. This is the Hebrew
Israelite framework. They don't know
theology.
Goodness gracious. Oh, this is awesome.
What essence are they made of?
>> I and I'm answering you directly, but
you're general.
>> Oh, you're giving an expiration date. I
want to know what essence are they made
from.
He said they are created father. That's
that's that's a that's a time limit.
What essence are they made from?
>> They are they they are they are
spiritually created. They are spirit
creatures.
>> Okay. What what is what is the sun? What
is the sun? Wait a minute. Wait, hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm asking you a
question. You're answering the
questions. He going to ask you another.
What is the sun?
>> No. I I didn't finish answering. So you
guys got to let me finish my What you
don't realize is Christianity like y'all
like to go on tangent and play word soup
and we like to get to the point. He
asked you what the I'm actually dealing
with you guys. I'm asking you what is
what is Christ's essence? What is he
made of?
>> All right. So can I answer this in full
without interruption?
>> I just need your answers quick. Let's
get to it.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz it should be simplicity. try. I'm
going try to answer you, my brother.
Every time I answer, you're interrupting
me. This is what This is what
Christianity does is cuz you don't in
Christianity know what the hell's going
on.
>> No, they don't.
>> Get to the point.
>> Oh, yeah. We We We know. Don't The only
thing that you have is Christianity is
stupid and nu. You don't have a real
argument. You're not refuting what I'm
saying.
>> Get to the point.
>> Yes, we are.
>> You You You haven't pulled one
scripture.
I I have I the scriptures that you guys
go to help me like like I'm glad we're
in Daniel
and you butcher you tried to make us
talk about Christ. That was Christ as a
local man. Come on. Hurry up.
>> Yeah. Get up off here. You ain't going
to get through this nowhere with him.
>> Go ahead. C man.
>> Conflation.
>> So there they go. There they go. They
kicked me off. They hung up on me.
[laughter]
Guys, my goodness. I'm not going to lie
to you, man. This was fun. That that was
really fun. But you guys you guys see
the cowardice. This is Christ. No, this
is Hebrew Israelism. This is Hebrew
Israelism. You guys cannot debate. You
guys cannot discuss. When you get
flustered when you guys actually meet
somebody that can challenge you and put
you in your place theologically, you get
flustered. You panic. You start
interrupting and talking over and
yelling over and now just spouting, "Oh,
this is Christianity is stupid. Oh,
you're just making stuff up." guys, I
didn't have to go anywhere. The verses
that you gave me destroyed you.
Destroyed you. Helped my point.
So, you know, uh that's Hebrew
Israelism. Uh we we we are on they they
are on my radar. They're on my radar.
And as you guys have seen, more content
is being put out debunking these pagans,
debunking these blasphemers, debunking
these idoltors, debunking these false
wolves, these false prophets, these
false teachers, false preachers. We are
on them. We're on them and we got the
numbers to do it. So, make sure you guys
hit the like button. Make sure you guys
subscribe if you guys want more of this.
you want to see me more uh engage with
these uh purple rangers and the black
ones and all all the other ones that's
out there. You guys want to see more of
this? [music] Make sure you guys
subscribe to the channel cuz you will be
seeing more content destroying,
humiliating, and [music] exposing the
Hebrew Israelite cult. And y'all know
what it is, man. Peace. [music]
Oh my god. Logic.
[music]
Heat. Heat. N.